[Music]
I mean hello how does it feel to be a
emmy-nominated star here tonight so
crazy I'm just so thankful I don't think
I would have imagined this in a million
years so I'm kind of just trying to
enjoy the ride has it been overwhelming
of sorts because obviously the attention
you guys got after doing stranger things
the love that barb got from fans and
then to be Emmy Emmy nominated me how
does this all feel I mean it's really
overwhelming you know I think I'll be
like handling and fine and then I'll
take a shower and I'll just start crying
like it's it's so much but it's
everything that I've like won it for
such a long time and I can only imagine
as a young actor how surreal it is I
mean have you given any thought to the
big night you have a dress picked out
yeah we're we're getting there I think I
have one that I like got my eye on so
I'm very excited about that and then
yeah I mean it's so cliche but it is
such an honor just to be nominated I
mean the other actresses I'm nominated
alongside are incredible so a dream
finally what can you tease about
Riverdale season two I guess all I can
really say is that a lot of people
thought the mystery was done with
finding out Jason's killer but season
two is even more intense there's gonna
be a lot of twists and turns so hold on
to your seats things are going to be
different now mommy
better you'll see
[Music]
you